♪♪
-Anyway, I know I spend
a lot of time
defending SeaWorld,
but they really do
a terrific job with the fish.
-Cool.
-Here's the check,
whenever you're ready.
No rush.
-He was great, by the way.
I think we tip him, right?
-Okay.
So, um, how should we do this?
-I mean, I guess
I could put it on my card.
-No, no, no. You don't --
You don't have to do that.
-If it's easier,
we can just split it six ways.
-Well, I mean, some people
had more than others.
-Did they?
-But let's just go through
and see who ordered what.
-Okay. That's fair.
-Diet Coke.
-That's me.
-Coke Zero.
-Sprite Zero.
-Me, as well.
Just obeying my thirst.
-Iced tea?
-Me.
-Arnold Palmer.
-Moi.
-Arnold Palmer with tequila.
-[ Laughs ]
Someone had to get
the party started.
-Whole roasted chicken,
extra potatoes.
-Sounds familiar.
-Flat-iron pork chops,
sub out broccoli for potatoes.
-Okay, no, no, no, no.
Wait.
That I ordered for the table,
although I probably did eat
the lion's share of it.
-98-ounce porterhouse steak.
-Okay. Don't look at me,
'cause I did not get that.
I'm serious.
I didn't get that.
There's no way.
Come on.
-There's a photo of you
on the wall, eating it.
-Well, maybe.
-Four bacon cheeseburgers to-go.
-Okay, I'm off the hot seat.
Bob, that's you.
-I'm a vegetarian.
-A little too much information.
-The Carson Daly,
a chicken broth and vodka.
-Yeah, I was trying
to switch it up.
A man cannot
live on tequila alone.
-"Five shots of tequila,
but leave them in the bathroom
so my friends don't find out"?
-Yeah, I'm actually more
concerned you called us friends.
-A dozen raw eggs,
still in the container.
-That, I'll admit,
was a little grocery shopping.
And I don't expect you guys
to pay for that.
-A bottle of your nicest white
wine with a note that says,
"Please take me back, Jennifer.
I am so, so, so sorry.
I know we can make this work
if you just tell
the judge you were lying."
-They wrote that on the bill?
Just to embarrass me?
-No, they charged you
because you asked for it
to be done by a calligrapher.
-It's beautiful.
-Bowl of turkey chili
with a rum floater.
-"Did I do that?"
Urkel.
-Another small side of potatoes.
-That actually was me.
Those potatoes did look good.
-And a Cadillac margarita?
Hey, it's 5:00 A.M.
somewhere, right?
-A.M.?
-Is anyone else
really blacking out right now?
[ Hand raps table ]
-Mr. Jackie
St. Croix St. Thomas,
we invited you to this meeting
because you said
you uncovered a map
that would show us the true
location of the Holy Grail.
-We've been more than patient
with you.
Now produce the map at once.
-There are interested parties --
Nazis -- who are
most eager to possess it.
-All right, I'm just
gonna come clean.
I'm not the successful dentist
turned janitor
turned influencer
you all thought I was,
and I don't have the map.
Because it belongs in a museum.
[ "Raiders March" plays ]
[ All gasp ]
-It's him!
-Dr. Indianapolis Bones?!
[ Whip cracks ]
-Not so fast, Dr. Bones.
-Nothing my trusty whip
can't hand--
[ Gunshot, body thuds ]
Ohh!
You killed him!
You kill Dr. Bones...
in the first episode?
Only on Amazon Prime.
We're still figuring it out.